[music]
Thank you very much for joining me today
yesterday Putin announced the partial
mobilization of the Russian army I wanted to
ask you what do you think about this news
but this is terrible news not only
in words it sounds like partial but do not
be deceived if you read  the
text of the
decree itself
is actually a complete mobilization, that
is, there you can call on anyone with an
exception only for those who are busy with the
industrial complex
and
I don’t know how they are going
to do logistics, but you need to understand
that
all the excuses that they call people
with military specialties and so on are
those who
I served in the army there for a
year, but we must understand that all
military departments, military specialties, the
annual service has long turned into
such a
little fiction. That is, these are not
trained people,
they are absolutely civilian people,
and as far as I understand, the Russian
Federation does not have any
system of structure for this  to
train these people quickly  Yes, I'm afraid that
this is such a step of desperation for the leadership of the
Russian Federation that will lead to
great sacrifices, but,
as it were, it will also be
absolutely useless.
to win also a useless step
and think that Putin believes on this topic
that he can somehow
somehow win this war, how to win this special operation
that he can win, or it seems
to be already a sign that he kind of knows that
he is losing now, as it were,
difficult  to say two here, I see two versions
1 he lives in a certain world of his own and believes
in the data that, for example
, the Minister of Defense announced today that the loss of the
Russian army there was 6 thousand
killed by the Ukrainian army 60 thousand, but then
the question arises of the presence of
logical thinking in general if
we are small forces  actually destroyed
half of the Ukrainian army Why do we need to
mobilize
either Yes, this is a kind of desperation step when
they understand that well, some consequences  their
deeds will be
and the
only chance before declaring
mobilization Perhaps somehow it will be possible
to defeat the
two options It’s hard to say which of
them is actually being implemented I think
that when they started it was absolutely certain
that they would
offend Ukraine There, in two or three days, the
population quickly  part with flowers This is clearly a
lack of information
implementation I was standing in a cafe and directly
told my companion that
mobilization was announced people started other people in the
queue immediately began to discuss
what is happening what a horror that is, I don’t
see any public support
except there is a propagandist
and maybe such  the situation is that there will be
some kind of protests, or how would
you think that this could be possible at all,
but for tonight, the already
announced rallies in large cities,
let's see how many people will come out,
but at the same time, you need to understand that people are very
afraid,
that is, there are a lot of people
talking privately  that we support you there with a
resignation letter Putin is there and we
support everything but say  no one
can publicly say this
oil
Yes, of course, a big risk for any
person Well, yes, I don’t think that
right now there will come such Awareness
that there is
an alternative to be
[music]
I think
that some more time will pass for
people to realize this
I see, thank you, this is also very
[music]
well, it leads to the fact that I also wanted to
ask you about the court that you
experienced last
week, this seems to be your second fine for the
fact that you, well, dragged you to court for
lending here  authorities 400 Excuse me,
you were fined 44 thousand rubles, this
seems to be your second fine. I wanted to
ask
if you could describe how the court
went, how you felt. What
happened at the court,
but the court actually made a painful
impression, because the
protocol is even bad  so important
for the police, they managed to make
mistakes for him,
up to indicating the wrong address where
everything happened, they didn’t write
the discrediting of the authorities consisted
because they attached a video in which the
deputies were standing on the porch and, in fact,
well, as if all the discrediting
on my part was that I raised
my hand for the decision
Uh-huh, it is unlikely that in some new reasonable
world this can be considered as discrediting
I like  the deputy is obliged to vote either for the
decision or against,
but nevertheless, all our arguments were
rejected, he
didn’t begin to deal with anything, he was
awarded a fine,
it’s clear that we will appeal here Yesterday,
literally with a lawyer, we read the
motivational part itself,
too, a lot of questions, a lot of
mistakes
If it were  it’s not a political matter,
then the protocol is canceled immediately with so many mistakes
and that’s
absolutely certain But in this case
we know that this is a political matter
because right in the materials of the body there is a
denunciation from the head of the district
Which is how the deputies write they are going to
vote for the
decision on the
request to consider the possibility
impeachment of Putin
FSB Ministry of Internal Affairs please take action
on the merits  it’s like such an obviously
political
order, these are the mistakes that you,
they kind of made mistakes on purpose, or
it’s like it’s just that
I don’t know, they were in a hurry, that is, we were
invited to the police station by
SMS messages at 11 pm, we
looked at the phone number and found out
that  this is a whole police lieutenant colonel, that
is, imagine the
scale of the commotion when the next
day after the decision at 11 pm, the
police lieutenant colonel sends SMS from his personal phone
so that we come by 9 am
to draw up a protocol. Well, that is, they were
just in a hurry, apparently.
I have the last question for you too
, even the fact that you are now
talking alone It seems to threaten you
[music]
as if a risk for you, the risk
seems to be small
Yes, and I just wanted to ask for the
audience, you can somehow explain too
Why are you like  do not drop this topic
Why is it so important for you to continue in
what you are doing now
I see
a great threat to m  of my
country
I want to live in this country and
what is in my power I am trying to do
all the more But if I was just a
citizen, maybe it would be possible to
take a position to remain silent does not
support but to be silent but I am a deputy
behind me 80,000 residents of the district
who, among other things, apply  they ask
me to express my position and Well, I try to
do it as much as possible as well as
my colleagues, but thanks to Dmitry Bystkov
it was very nice to discuss this topic with you
[music]